[Music]
hello everyone welcome to et live i'm
denny director i'm selfish lazy we are
breaking down what you guys can expect
from this sunday's Grammy Awards I can't
believe it's ready at this time again I
can't either
her favorite award show I'd say it but
yeah we're gonna break down you guys the
predictions for the major categories
also what performances to us expect and
also what host James Corden has up his
sleeve of course you want to hear from
you guys so make sure you're leaving
your comments below and we'll get them
right here to this iPad but first we got
to talk about jay-z's domination this
year he is leading the pack with eight
total nominations guys get this he is
now a 74 time nominee and a 21 time
winner my guys just racking them up but
he is so good jay-z and uh and be mrs.
or mr. Beyonce I should think
but he's nominated alongside with
Beyonce actually four wraps on
collaboration and trailing him is
Kendrick Lamar with seven nominations
and Bruno Mars with six so it's gonna be
a fun race to watch oh we're actually
gonna break down some of the major
categories yes now I'm gonna give you
guys my predictions I'm gonna hear yours
though so hit the comments below and let
us know what you think because do we
really know what but here's what I do
think I think it's gonna be jay-z vs
Kendrick Lamar this year jay-z's got
eight nominations Kendricks got seven
they're up in a lot of the same
categories including album of the year
so I'm gonna go ahead and guess that
Kendrick Lamar damn is gonna take album
of the year I don't know it's that's
just my gut feeling
it could definitely be jay-z I would say
one of those two but I'm gonna go with
Kendra it's so hard to pick because you
have jay-z who's obviously in industry
icon he's been in the game for a long
time Kendrick is one of the most well
revered critically acclaimed artists and
a lot of people feel like he's been
robbed in the past you know he's been
nominated for album of the year before I
think this is the album to finally take
it I think there's a possibility that
they could split the boat totally let
the vote I'm sorry as well and it's
worth noting that if either of them does
win this year it would be the first
hip-hop artist to take that award since
2004 when Outkast took it that's one
thing it's so overdue you know it's long
overdue and I think Kendrick is the one
do it but like you mentioned they could
split the vote you got two major hip-hop
artists here and that's why I'm gonna
make a a case for lor she might be the
dark horse in this race it's her only
nomination but melodrama was critically
acclaimed I loved it
and I feel like if they split the vote
it might go her way but that's a shot in
the dark there and you know Childish
Gambino's also nominated Bruno Mars it's
the heavy hitters in Matagorda Grammys
love Bruno so absolutely now let's get
into record of the year record of the
year and song of the year always some
confusion here now record of the year is
for the total package the song the
production the performance all of that
good stuff I think it's got to be dust
for seed out yeah that song was
everywhere last year it broke records at
every turn it was on every radio station
at any given moment I mean breaking
records globally yeah this song was hot
even before Justin Bieber got on the
remix the remix is the song that's
nominated for record of the year and
you're right it's so inescapable I feel
like it will and should win I feel like
it's that's my seat those year I think
it's deserved I think so love it or hate
it I feel like it needs to take it I
know you guys heard on the radio a lot
but there really was no bigger record
yeah yeah well unless you're counting
some Bruno Mars
there was a lot of Bruno Mars in here um
he is up in that category he's also up
for song of the year I think that's what
I like might take song in the air now
this is the one that goes for song
writing the lyrics the Grammy voters
love Bruno they always have I think he's
gonna take it you and I were talking
about this and it's like there's not a
clear front-runner I don't think in
these top four categories so we're
trying to spread the love here and I
think this is where Bruno will come on
top he last one record of the year for
uptown funk this one will be for
songwriting and I think that's what I
like is is his you know he's did a
resistance when it comes to the
songwriting you know so this is the way
look at that video this is a huge hat
that's what I'm saying if he's gonna
take one of these it might be this one
yeah yeah I think so now getting into
Best New Artist now this one could be a
little a lot of opinions going around
for this one so my prediction is gonna
be scissor she's so critically acclaimed
she's actually the most nominated female
artist this year she's just awesome and
everybody I've kind of talked to in the
office has agreed with me I think it's
gonna be Sousa so I'm keeping my fingers
crossed for her and
you not talked about this a lot actually
Susan is amazing a breakthrough artist
of the year for sure for me I feel like
Alessia Cara might be the one to take
this only because I feel like when you
look back when you look back at the past
best new artist winners it's people like
Sam Smith it's people like Meghan
Trainor champ the rapper took it last
year Alessi has been on the charts
longer kind of commercial exactly she's
way more mainstream and I feel like the
Grammy voters like to award that person
they could see just taking it all the
way past this this category like
Christina Aguilera and Adele people have
a potential for career longevity sure I
feel like it's Alessia very true so why
motifs first cezzah but I would not at
all be surprised if Alessi exactly let
us know you guys we want to know who you
guys are thinking in fact clay you're
saying you're rooting for Kendrick
that's right yeah says yes despots Ito
and Gabi he's excited for James as the
house James Corden is back hosting again
I'm excited to see him too we have a
little tease from him on what we can
expect from the wardrobe coming up but
but you know what this is what I love
about the Grammy Awards it's not just
about the wars in fact I think it's
probably more about the performances
absolutely and there are so many this
year it's a crazy long list just to
start we've got Lady Gaga pink so
excited to see pink Kendrick Lamar and
this one I know you're very excited for
I cannot wait for Bruno Mars and cardi B
degree set stage they're performing the
finesse remix you guys seen the video by
now it look there it is oh look it I
can't wait to see those live on the
grant how about the Grammys let's talk
about this though do you think it's
gonna be just a redo of the music video
are they gonna do something now so we
actually spoke with Phillip Lawrence who
is one of Bruno's guys in the hooligans
you've seen him in the Uptown funk video
you've seen him in the 24k magic video
and he told ET that they're actually
gonna do something a little more fresh
something new so I mean every time Bruno
hits the Grammy stage people are up on
their feet I'm at home watch excuse me I
should say the office I'm at the office
of my feet like this gonna be epic and
to be performing with cardi B who's one
of the biggest artists of 2017
I just can't wait and that song is
fighters start abusing other nominees
I'm so excited for her I think she might
take it her category 602 Brody come on
now other performances up performer
services that's not a word performances
include childish gambino we got Rihanna
dj khaled and Bryson tiller doing wild
thoughts which would be fun
Kesha I'm excited to see Kesha I hope
that she takes her very first Grammy
this year she's up for an award in the
pop categories and this has been such
like a reinvention year for her and
especially with the times up in me too
initiative going on in everything that's
going on with Kesha I think that she's
getting a ton of support right now in
the industry I would expect her to
really bring it on Sunday I have a
feeling because of what you just said
that might be one of the most talked
about moments of the night for sure and
it's hard to believe that this is her
first time there so I'm excited to watch
that moment for her as well I'm so
excited to see Elton John and Miley
Cyrus perform come on Miley doing a
little Elton Elton just announced that
he's retiring from touring so we got to
see him live as as often as we can these
next three years kicking off at the
Grammys and another duo teaming up is
Chris Stapleton and Emmylou Harris
Emmylou is being honored with lifetime
achievement award she's a legend she is
the most winningest female artist of all
time at the Grammys just total icon
status and Chris Stapleton amazing I
know a lot of people are wondering if
Justin Timberlake is gonna pop in and
surprise because you know Chris and
Justin just did this incredible yeah say
something
video today we're hearing that Justin is
not going to be there I'm inclined to
believe it only because this is Emmy
lose moment Chris is there for Emmy Lou
and not to mention the fact that JT is a
little busy guy planning for a Super
Bowl halftime show which is a week from
the Grammys so he's I think he's in that
incubation period and like you know he's
good he's got to save it for the the big
football stage you know he's busy let's
talk about this rumor though there's
been a lot of rumors that Beyonce and
jay-z could perform together Denny what
do you think is going to happen
obviously jay-z is leading the pack like
I mentioned with the most nominations
he's nominated with Beyonce in the rap
song category which by the way if they
win for a family feud it'll be their
fifth joint Grammy win if you guys can
believe it they've won previously
together for crazy and love and drunken
love notice a theme know so yeah the
speculation is will they or will they
not perform we know they're gonna be
there not just because the nominations
but because et was inside the auditorium
and they are their seating cards are
there
Beyonce and jay-z shockingly enough will
be sitting next to each other and they
inside the audience but could it predict
I know exactly but when they perform
while we went straight to the source
guys host James Corden we caught up with
them at the official Grammys red-carpet
rollout and here's what he's got to say
about this potential performance by the
Carters I know Beyonce's on your bucket
list is she gonna be on the Grammy
bucket list will she perform this year
she knows no she performed last year pop
out with jay-z the most nominated
gentleman of the night what to perform
with him I don't think he's performing
either so I think they'll be there but I
don't think I don't think jay-z's
performing so you just see him backstage
I guess yeah I imagine he will have a
pass I can't tell from his like I can't
tell if that's a pokerface if he's being
serious or is he just trying to like you
know he looks so cool and collected and
I said this to you before they have lied
to us so many times over the years
liquors Recording Academy about what to
expect because they want the art of the
surprise I get that but at this point
it's like how do you manage expectations
but also like not have people just think
that you're lying
I just you'll expect it I don't know who
to believe anymore I don't know who to
believe anything could happen I'm
holding out for that performance but
James says it's not gonna happen
I'm also jay-z will be honored the night
before at Clive Davis's annual pre Gant
Grammy gala saluting industry icons so
maybe it's a busy weekend maybe he just
would be off the hook enjoy sip on a
drink and watch the show nothing but you
know James also teases a very very big
performance we'll be opening the show he
says it's not him so there was a rumor
that it might be Kendrick opening the
show see I'm telling you it's his year I
feel like this is the year for Kendrick
and damp yeah we need it
Dominique Savage is asking where his
blue sea great question haha you know
she stole this show last year I can't
wait to see what she's wearing last
year's award this custom little Gucci
suit she popped into James Karp okay we
will definitely be there I got if mom
and dad are there I'm guaranteeing blue
we'll be so North yg was asking is
Taylor Swift going to perform all right
listen I do not think she's going to
perform I've my gut is telling me she's
not she is nominated twice though she
actually wrote little big town's better
man which is up for best country song
and
she also wrote the 50 shades darker song
I don't wanna live forever that one's
nominated as well for visual media so
she I
I predict Taylor will actually win okay
at least one of those it's been a while
so she's collected a trophy for a
country song performance right I think
she's gonna win I think she's not going
to be there to accept in person I do not
think she did inform but hey she could
totally surprise us you know she's got
the reputation to her coming up it's
true some sales I don't know what I mean
I'm hoping she shows up show but the
boyfriend I dare you to allure
alright Gabi's excited for Pink's
performance we were talking about like
will she be scaling buildings will she
be hanging from the ceiling of Madison
ya know like I'm gonna I'm gonna just
say that she's probably gonna do some
kind of air about acrobatic performance
you never know but I mean pink always
consistently delivers if there's one
thing you know pink is going to give us
an incredible performance I would
actually love to see her do the routine
with Channing Tatum okay yeah hi cherry
we want to see your moves at the Grammys
clay agrees with us agrees with us this
is the year for Kendrick Thank You clay
clay yeah preciate you guys all right
we'll be live from the red carpet at the
Grammys you guys and immediately
following the Grammys show we will be
doing a recap here on Twitter and
YouTube so we'll be talking about the
biggest moments and of course the best
performances and there's so much more ET
online.com I know your predictions are
up right I have a full list of
predictions up on ET online.com so you
guys can check that out there alright
well thank you guys so much for tuning
in this is what you can expect from the
Grammys and again joining us Sunday
right after the show for a live recap
enjoy the rest of your weekend we'll see
you then bye
[Music]
you